[Musik]
der Schrecken den der russische Überfall
auf die Ukraine dem Westen eingejagt hat
zeigt unvermindert Wirkung modernste
Waffentechnologie der NATO-Länder strömt
in die Ukraine was ich Wladimir Putin
offenbar überhaupt nicht vorstellen
konnte eine rote Linie nach der anderen
die er gezogen hat wurde überschritten
immer schwerere Waffen werden geliefert
denn der NATO ist völlig klar was ein
sie Putins auch für sie bedeutet
inzwischen sind wir bei Kampfjets
angelangt aus westlicher Produktion
Kampfjet für die Ukraine droht eine
Eskalation jetzt der königsrunde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Johannes alt ist bei uns im Hauptberuf
Luftwaffen Offizier der Bundeswehr sie
sind im Moment freigestellt für die SPD
und sitzen seit 2021 im Bundestag und im
Verteidigungsausschuss Rüdiger Lukassen
ebenfalls im Verteidigungsausschuss des
Bundestages ehemaliger Oberst im
Generalstab der Bundeswehr seit 2017 im
Parlament und verteidigungspolitischen
Sprecher und ob man der AFD im
Verteidigungsausschuss Julia Berghofer
ist Expertin für Sicherheitspolitik beim
European leadership Network eine ein
Netzwerk von jungen Europäern die
Führungsansprüche eines Tages anmelden
werden und der Journalist Thomas Wiegold
schreibt in seinem Block Augen geradeaus
über verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitspolitik und die Bundeswehr
außerdem sind sie kohaus
Podcasts sicherheitshalber ja wie Gold
nach der Diskussion um die
Panzerlieferungen hier in Deutschland
scheinen die Lieferung weiterer Waffen
nicht so umstritten zu sein in
Deutschland
wo dann liegt das hat sich das
insofern geklärt dass klar ist welche
Rolle die Deutschland in diesem Konflikt
spielen muss also da bin ich nicht
sicher ich glaube dass diese Kampfjets
Lieferung die er noch nicht final ist
also die zu erwarten ist dass diese
Lieferung in Deutschland deswegen nicht
so umstritten ist weil die Bundeswehr
die Jets eben nicht hat über die
gesprochen wird die Ukraine hat
Interesse an F16 Kampfflugzeugen aus den
USA davon gibt es in der NATO sehr sehr
viele eben nicht in Deutschland damit
für viele in der Wahrnehmung kein
deutsches Thema Frau Berghofer selenski
war ja in den letzten Tagen regelrecht
dafür wärmetruhe für mehr Unterstützung
vor allem militärische Unterstützung
Ukraine also auch auf dem
die sieben Treffen in Hiroshima hat er
denn die Partner also die Partner in der
G7 überzeugen können
ja also ich denke das was wir jetzt
sehen kann man natürlich als eine Art
schamoffensive sehen die natürlich
vollkommen notwendig ist also es ist ja
so dass nicht alles was sich die Ukraine
wünscht automatisch aus den westlichen
Ländern geliefert wird deswegen ist das
was wir sehen einfach eine sehr logische
sehr logisches Verhalten von
ukrainischer Seite und ich denke es hat
Anklang gefunden in Europa es ist
natürlich jetzt auch keine total
überraschende Debatte ich glaube was wir
sehen ist einfach eine logische
Fortsetzung von einer Entwicklung die
sich seit letztem Jahr abgezeichnet hat
und ich denke die Lieferung von
Kampfjets ist jetzt einfach ja eine
logische eine logische Weiterentwicklung
Glück für Deutschland der alt dass wir
keine F16 Kampfflugzeuge in unseren
Depot sind in unserem Bestand haben da
kann sich der Bundeskanzler Thomas wie
konntet jetzt erstmal etwas entspannt
zurücklehnen und muss vor allem nicht
den widerspenstigen Teil der
SPD-Fraktion erklären dass man
möglicherweise doch noch Kampflugzeuge
liefern muss
ja ich glaube wir müssen uns nicht
zurücklehnen wir müssen auch nicht
verstecken mit dem Unterstützungspaket
was wir geliefert haben im letzten Jahr
und was wir jetzt liefern werden wir
haben gesagt wir konzentrieren uns auf
gewisse Cluster das ist Artillerie das
sind gepanzerte Fahrzeuge das ist
Flugabwehr und das sind auch
pioniergeräte und das sind die Klasse
die wir halt im Wesentlichen beliefern
das tun wir auch weiterhin bei all
diesen Clustern hat der Olaf Scholz am
Anfang auch gesagt Neo liefern wenn
nicht dann hat das hat Deutschland ist
doch gemacht in das gleiche Schicksal
möglicherweise auch bei Kampfflugzeugen
es ist ja auch schon nach den Tornados
gefragt worden ja beim Tornado muss man
wissen dass man für eine Flugstunde
ungefähr 200 Mechaniker Stunden
aufwenden muss ist ein sehr sehr altes
Waffensystem was ich am Ende der
Nutzungsphase befindet wo das auf
Service Date in Sichtweite ist also auf
deutsch gesagt sehr schwer das zu
implementieren nicht nur für die
Pilotenausbildung sondern vor allen
Dingen die technischen logistische Kette
ist eben das bei einer Implementierung
eines Luftfahrzeugs was dann wirklich
komplex wird von der Techniker
Ausbildung der Erfahrung die man
brauchen die Luftfahrzeuge repariert zu
reparieren aber eben auch die
Ersatzteile Pakete bereits
die F16 ist ein großer Zahl einer NATO
vorhandener hat darauf hingewiesen und
sicherlich deshalb einfacher auch
bereitzustellen wenn man das dann möchte
lukasten
sie haben gesagt militärische Hilfe des
Westens würde keinen Siegfrieden
Siegfrieden gegen Russland erreichen und
zu einem ruinösen abnutzungskrieg führen
also ich habe den Eindruck es gibt nur
einen der auf Siegfrieden setzt und das
ist Wladimir Putin ähm
instinuieren sie nicht mit diesem Satz
dass die NATO die Ukraine aufrüstet und
dann sozusagen gemeinsam Russland
abzubuchen als
langjähriger Bundeswehroffizier müssten
Sie ja wissen dass das eigentlich
abwegig ist diese NATO-Strategie die
Bundeswehr kann das ja gar nicht einen
Siegfrieden gegen Russland mit der
Ukraine mit der NATO zu starten nein
dann Siegfrieden ist ja insofern auch
nicht erreichbar aber sehen Sie
die Frage der Eskalation oder die Frage
wie viel Waffen müssen dann geliefert
werden um ein gegebenes Ziel wobei ich
das kriegstil nicht kenne ähm zu
erreichen diese diese Antwort darauf
gibt es ja gar nicht wir wissen das ja
gar nicht wie viel er Waffen
erforderlich wären um tatsächlich die
Russische Föderation die russischen drei
Kräfte abzuhalten und zur Abnutzung der
Keller seit fünf Jahren fünf Monaten er
steht dieser Krieg auf der Stelle auf
dem Gefechtsfeld und es ist eine
Abnutzung ohne das ein eine Seite ein
signifikanten
grün davon hat was meinen Sie denn genau
mit diesem Begriff Siegfrieden der
stammt ja aus dem ersten Weltkrieg und
meinte dass das wilhelminische
Kaiserreich die Westmächte in die Knie
zwingen wollte auf dem Schlachtfeld was
meinen Sie in dem Zusammenhang mit
Siegfrieden naja dass die Russische
Föderation auch für die Zukunft gelähmt
ist ähnliche Angriffe durchzuführen das
wäre das Ziel also tatsächlich so weit
in die Schranken zu verweisen dass keine
weitere militärische merkbare
militärische Bedrohung von der
Russischen Föderation ausgehen kann das
finden die Ukraine und die Osteuropäer
in der NATO aber wahrscheinlich ziemlich
gut wenn Russland war defensivfähigkeit
sich zu verteidigen aber nicht mehr
anzugreifen wie es geht das kann keiner
sein wie es geht
schauen wir uns den F16 das Flugzeug
noch mal an da USA Großbritannien und
Frankreich wollen jetzt eine
Kampfjet Koalition bilden interessant
ist das ja die USA zwar diese Flugzeuge
herstellt aber wahrscheinlich nicht in
Frankreich hat sie gar nicht
kann man sagen dass für diese drei
Länder das ein Versprechen ist dass sie
eigentlich wenig kostet
es ist ein politisches Signal und ich
kann Piloten natürlich gut ausbilden in
vorhandenen Ausbildungseinrichtung das
eine Sache die ich auch machen kann in
meinem Land der zweite Schritt eine
Lieferung wirklich von Plattformen an
die Ukraine mit all den Konsequenzen die
ich dargestellt habe auch fürs technisch
logistische System das bringt da nichts
wenn ich die einmal Lieferung die dann
stehen nach einem Flug oder gar nicht
abheben können das ist noch mal ein
völlig anderer Schritt wäre auch
sicherheitspolitisch noch mal ganz
anders zu bewerten ist also der Schritt
einzusteigen die Ausbildung von Piloten
ist ein relativ einfacher auch wenn es
ein wichtiges Signal ist
was ist denn da eigentlich Thomas
Wiegold genau zugesagt worden jetzt was
diese F16 Lieferungen angeht gar nichts
also Lieferung gar nicht sondern mit dem
OK von US-Präsident beiden für eine
Ausbildung die ja vor allem
Großbritannien sehr propagiert hatte
zuvor andere Länder auch ein bisschen
ist klar diese Ausländer Ausbildung kann
stattfinden auch auf diesem
Flugzeugmuster und die Entscheidung
meine Lieferung sein zweiter Schritt
aber ich möchte gerne aufgreifen was er
halt gesagt hat nämlich die Ausbildung
vorgelagert einer Lieferung von
Plattformen wie sie gesagt haben das ist
deswegen interessant frankreich hat
keine Effekt den Großbritannien hat
keine F16 sagt aber wir bilden aus und
damit wird zwangsläufig die Frage auch
auf Deutschland zukommen Deutschland hat
keine F16 aber Ausbildung analog zu
Frankreich oder groß Kastanien ist dann
hier genauso möglich also insofern wird
kann sich Deutschland nicht raushalten
aus der Frage die kommen wird
unterstützt die Bundesregierung diese
Kampfjet Koalition auch ohne eigene
flugzeuglieferung die Frage ist ja Frau
Berghofer wenn wir ausbilden in diesem
bei dieser bei dieser Maschine die in
Deutschland ja ein großer Zahl vorhanden
ist und zwar auf den
us-luftaffenstützpunkt möglicherweise
ist das ja auch gemeint die
Waffensysteme der deutschen Kampfjets
also Tornado vor allen Dingen und die
der F 16 sind ja in der operabel wie man
so schön sagt also sie können
unterschiedliche weil es nicht bei
gleichen Waffensysteme die da sozusagen
angeschraubt werden können wie würde da
möglicherweise dann Russland darauf
reagieren zu sagen also Deutschland
liefert zwar keine Flugzeuge keine F16
aber sie schaffen die eine erhebliche
Logistik dass diese Flugzeuge nicht nur
die Ukraine kommen sondern dann dort
auch einge es werden gegen russische
Truppen also ich würde mal sagen das ist
eine Frage die ja nicht nur Deutschland
betrifft sondern das ist eine Frage die
die NATO generell betrifft also ich
glaube wenn es um eskalationsrisiken
geht dann müssen wir die uns immer von
gesamten nato-perspektive anschauen weil
ich denke nicht dass wir jetzt irgendwie
Aggressionen mögliche Aggressionen
Russlands gegen einen spezifisches Land
nehmen wir jetzt Deutschland sehen
sondern wenn dann ist es eine Frage die
wir uns als nato-gesamt stellen müssen
die Nato hat sich bestimmte rote Linien
gegeben schon zu Beginn des Krieges
diese roten Linien wurden nicht
überschritten diese roten Linien
beinhalten dass eben schwere Waffen
geliefert werden das Training
bereitgestellt wird das bestimmte andere
Ausbildungsmaßnahmen auch von zivilen
Personal stattfinden also ich denke
diese ganze eskalationsthematik sollten
wir von dem anderen Gesichtspunkt
Aussehen nämlich dass Russland ja
bewusst eskalationsrisiken hoch hält das
sehen wir immer noch in der Situation um
das
Kraftwerk herum dass immer noch
okkupiert ist von russischer Seite das
sehen wir beispielsweise über dem
Schwarzen Meer als als diese
amerikanische Drohne zum Absturz
gebracht wurde also die Frage für mich
ist eine prinzipiell andere nämlich wie
kann man Russland dazu bringen auf einen
dr eskalierenden Weg zu gehen die NATO
selber hält sich an die roten Linien die
Sie sich gesetzt hat und dazu gehört
natürlich auch Deutschland Russland hat
ja bisher häufiger schon gedroht den
Westen eines Kriegspartei anzusehen sie
sieht uns ja eigentlich als Kriegspartei
anders sind im Zusammenhang auch mit der
Lieferung der Panzer ja schon so gewesen
der frühere russische Präsident Eva die
ja da wüste Drohungen gegen den Westen
ausgestoßen
ändert sich jetzt durch die nach ihrer
Einschätzung durch die mögliche oder
geplante Lieferung der Kampfjets da noch
etwas oder wird das wird Putin das dann
hinnehmen wird sagen gut hat ja auch
noch verkünden lassen dass diese F 16
völlig untauglich in der Ukraine also
muss es ja eigentlich aus russischer
Sicht gar nicht so Problem Mensch sein
dass die Ukraine jetzt diese Flugzeuge
kriegt also sie sprechen einen wichtigen
Punkt an und das ist eben die
Wahrnehmung aus russischer Sicht aus
Putins Sicht wann ist eine Eskalation
aus seiner Sicht erreicht die er nicht
mehr zulassen kann so und wir sollten
uns nicht nur über dieses Thema also in
diesem Falle
Kampfjets unterhalten sondern wir
sollten uns über die Fähigkeiten
unterhalten die damit auf das
Gefechtsfeld gebracht werden und das ist
ja nicht der ist der F16 alleine es ist
vor allen Dingen auch die mögliche
Bewaffnung und in diesem Zusammenhang
ist ja auch Taurus im Gespräch und
Taurus eben halt durch den F16 verbracht
zu werden und da müssen wir wissen dass
diese dass diese Munition dass diese
Waffe bis zu 500 km weit schießen kann
das heißt über den Gefechtsfeld
verbracht kann sie bei 500 km bis Moskau
wirken so das ist eine Wahrnehmung die
Putin dann erreichen kann und da müssen
wir uns wirklich Fragen wollen wir so
weit gehen egal ob die nat rote Linien
gesetzt hat oder nicht das ist schon
eine andere Qualität entschuldigung da
muss ich mal eben rein die Frage stellen
diese Linie um die rot ist oder nicht
ist ja bereits überschritten mit der
Lieferung der britischen Storm Shadow
mit der
Marschflugkörper der
so genau weiß man es immer nicht wie
weit der fliegen kann aber im Grunde
genommen das britische Äquivalent zum
deutschen Taurus oder zum französischen
Skype der auch angekündigt wurde das
heißt
die Deutschen ein eine mögliche wenn
auch bislang vom Minister nicht
gewollte oder abgelehnte taures
Lieferung ist eigentlich völlig
unerhebliches Luftfahrzeug dazu das war
bei Storm Schild nicht der Fall
aber bevor
trotzdem es gibt ja Hinweise darauf dass
die Ukraine diese britischen
ausflugkörper an eine Ex sowjetische
su24 in ihren Beständen integriert hat
also einsetzen konnten sie die oder
können Sie die bereits jetzt
sehr kreativ bei der Integration von
neuen Waffentypen ist und neue
Kombinationen ausprobiert hat das hat er
schon vielfach weitergeholfen und
Luftwaffe hat sie ja eine ganze Reihe
von Big 29 Flugzeugen aus Altbeständen
der osteuropäischen
Nato-Partner bevor wir interessant ist
dieser Aspekt der mit dem
Marschflugkörper denn es gibt ja von
einem bundestagskollegen von ihnen von
der CDU von rodrig Kiesewetter den
Vorschlag die auch zu liefern aber noch
vorher eine andere Frage die zu dem
vorgesagten gehört
die Ukraine sichert ja immer zu dass sie
die Waffen die sie ja möglicherweise
offensiv Waffen diese Zurückeroberung
von dornbas und Grimm einsetzen will
eben nicht auf russischen Territorium
einsetzt sind Sie sicher dass das auch
so bleiben wird vertraut Deutschland der
Ukraine der Ukraine
ich denke das Deutschland grundsätzlich
schon den Zusagen der Ukraine vertraut
aber die Frage nach Hause stellt sich im
Moment nicht und ich muss sagen dass der
Kollege Kiesewetter auch ein ehemaliger
Soldat übrigens dort gemacht hat
inklusive möglicherweise operationell
betriebsfähiger Taurus zu publizieren
finde ich einfach verantwortungslos und
zeigt dass wir einfach überhaupt nicht
in einer gewohnt sind in Deutschland
über Sicherheit zu diskutieren solche
Zahlen die kommuniziert man nicht in den
Medien
so noch sagen welche wir nicht
kommunizieren wollen nämlich das von 600
Taurus möglicherweise nur 150
einsatzbereit sind dazu braucht man nur
kurz einmal online gehen also das ist ja
nur kein Geheimnis ja
gut also diese diese das war der
Vorschlag zu anderen Marschflugkörpern
sowas wie Gold was bedeutet das der
Einsatz dieser Marschflugkörper ist das
vielleicht das entscheidende
gefechtsvorteil die Russen haben ja auch
immer für die Ukraine dass sie dann auch
wirklich auf breiter Front angreifen
kann nicht nur den russischen Firma
stoppen
sowieso gar nicht mehr stattfindet
sondern eben auch das was sie ja vor hat
nämlich die völkerrechtswie sich
besetzten Gebiete in der Ukraine
zurückzuholen also diese
Marschflugkörper diese britischen
bislang nur sind die am weitesten
reichenden Waffen die der besten bisher
der Ukraine zur Verfügung gestellt hat
es gab ja seit über einem Jahr immer die
de oder den Wunsch der Ukraine von den
USA Raketen mit einer Reichweite von 300
Kilometern zu bekommen die haben sie
nicht bekommen über die Gründe können
wir jetzt auch lange spekulieren aber
mit diesen Storm Shadow bekommt die
Ukraine genauso etwas nämlich
Waffenreichweite seines 300 seines 350
seines 400 aber so etwas in der
Größenordnung das hatte sie vorher nicht
und der zweite Punkt ist diese
Marschflugkörper sind speziell dafür
entwickelt worden
verbunkerte Kommando Stellung
anzugreifen also
gesicherte Kommando Stellungen Depots
Schaltzentralen im Grunde genommen und
damit hat die Ukraine natürlich
erheblich mehr Möglichkeiten insofern
wenn wir über Game changer über über
neue Fähigkeiten Reden sind die
marschflocke aber glaube ich ein
wesentlich wichtiger Teil als ist die
Frage welche Jets kommen wann zumal die
Jets auch noch dauern Alter ich glaube
das sind mal vor zehn Jahren 800 Stück
angeschafft worden dass sie noch 20
einsatzfähig ist das richtig von diesen
Taurus marschko Körper die wir ja
offiziell gibt's diese Zahl noch nicht
wir wissen es 500 angeschafft worden
sind aber über den
über dem über den Zustand wie gesagt
über den Zustand gibt es eigentlich
keine offiziellen Angaben die dazu
gemacht werden von BVG und ich finde wir
vernachlässigen ein bisschen bei dieser
Debatte das im Wesentlichen die Ukraine
ja gehindert ihre bodenoperation
durchführen will darum geht's ja
letztendlich dass die Gefahr aus der
Luft minimiert wird und da leisten wir
eben mit der Luft Verteidigung mit der
Flugabwehr die wir dort liefern in
verschiedensten Komponenten System das
haben wir in den letzten Tagen auch
gesehen bei der Nacht Angriffen ein ganz
ganz wesentlichen Beitrag und darum
finde ich auch also um von Game chillen
das zu sprechen das mag vielleicht sein
aber ich halte das für gar nicht so
wichtig wenn sie jetzt gerade sagen
wofür man eben diese
Bewaffnung einsetzen kann
wenn die Ukraine ätheritorium
zurückerobern möchte dann halte ich vor
allen Dingen ein vor allen Dingen eine
funktionierenden Flugabwehr für einen
gamechanger der dann auch dazu führen
kann dass die Ukraine eben diesen Krieg
nicht verliert Robert noch mal eine ganz
grundsätzliche Frage jetzt würden ja
immer mehr Waffensysteme kommen ins
Spiel immer moderner immer effektiver
immer effizienter
immer mehr auch militärisch wohl
nützlich und nutzbar das war ja nicht
immer so ich habe jetzt schon kurz die
exeges in Deutschland gesprochen die
Diskussion erst keine Kampfbahn sondern
doch weil also es könnte Schützen waren
sondern doch welche dann keine kampfpart
sondern doch welche mal gucken wie das
mit den Flugzeugen weitergeht und mit
Marschflugkörpern die USA haben sich ja
bei der im 16
bei der 16
Möglichkeiten alles möglich
wieso gibt es plötzlich dieses Umdenken
bei den bei der NATO und auch bei der
bei den sieben Staaten das kann er nicht
alleine an der überzeugungs und dem
rasismatischen Auftreten von selenetz
gelegen also ich würde erstmal sagen
dass es nicht unbedingt ein
grundsätzliches Umdenken ist sondern wie
ich schon am Anfang gesagt habe wir
sehen ja eine Entwicklung und ich glaube
diese Entwicklung findet parallel dazu
statt dass man natürlich schaut sowohl
von von NATO Seite als auch das von der
Ukraine selbst kommuniziert bekommt
welche welche Fähigkeiten werden in der
Ukraine gerade gebraucht um im Moment
geht es eben darum dass also beide
Seiten wieder Russland noch die Ukraine
haben ja momentan die Luft Hoheit und
diesen Status gilt es zu erhalten es
geht auch darum dass Luftfahrzeuge die
die wie sie bereits gesagt haben die
bodenoperation unterstützen bisher war
eben die bodenoperation der große der
große Fokus und jetzt kommt die Ukraine
eben in eine Position wo man sagt macht
das eben sind jetzt zu liefern also ich
glaube insgesamt findet das ähm ich
schaue mich mal ein bisschen davor zu
sagen es gibt ein großes Umdenken oder
das ist jetzt alles das alles ein Game
changer weil ich glaube das sind alles
logische Entwicklungen die man im
Verhandlungen mit der Ukraine austariert
und natürlich gab es auch in den in den
USA viele Überlegungen dazu macht das
Sinn diese Fähigkeiten zu liefern sie
haben bereits die Problematik
angesprochen die sich um die Wartung
dreht auch um die Tatsache dass die
Start- und Landebahn in der Ukraine für
die F16 momentan nicht unbedingt fit
sind das Problem dass hier Piloten
trainieren müssen und nicht wissen wie
lange es dauert
Wartungspersonal an für sich ist ein ist
ein riesen Ding sind das Ukrainer oder
sind das externe die unter Vertrag
genommen werden und da gab es im im März
einen ganz interessanten sehr
umfassenden Bericht des congressional
research Service der das wirklich Punkt
für Punkte untersucht hat also ich
glaube man darf auch nicht die Debatte
zu sehr politisieren obwohl sie das
natürlich ist sondern dahinter stehen
natürlich auch technische Überlegungen
da stehen Überlegungen was haben welche
Länder was können sie auch abgeben sie
haben ja bereits angesprochen
F16 ist ja jetzt nicht überall verfügbar
also frankreich hat sie nicht Länder wie
Portugal Rumänien Slowakei haben sie
Dänemark Norwegen es geht ja auch in
Griechenland glaube ich noch also schon
eine ganze Reihe von
nato-1.600f 16 allein in Europa bei
NATO-Ländern außer USA statt man sollte
aber noch mal sehen was sie gerade
gesagt haben ist ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt in dieser Untersuchung des
Kongresses stand nämlich eben auch drin
das unter anderem für einen normalen
Techniker an diesem Flugzeug 233 Tage
Grundausbildung erforderlich sind plus
ein Jahr professions die Phase also
erfahrungsphase um überhaupt
eigenverantwortlich einem Luftfahrzeug
schrauben zu können selbst wenn sie
sagen sie nehmen das ein bisschen runter
und kürzen die Zeit ein bisschen ein und
betrachten das so als Friedens geplante
Ausbildung sehen Sie also den Zeitrahmen
den wir ungefähr haben bis wir überhaupt
Personal aber dann eigentlich ohne
Erfahrung zur Verfügung haben diesen
Luftfahrzeugen zu schrauben das habe ich
glaube wirklich das ist allererst ein
politisches Signal ist und nicht
wirklich jetzt schon der gezeigte Willen
dieses Thema wirklich sich in der
Ukraine zu implementieren weil es sind
riesige Herausforderungen die man nicht
unterschätzen darf sie haben von der
stufenweise Weiterentwicklung gesprochen
was das Einbringen von Waffensystem an
betrifft schützenpanzerkampfpanzer jetzt
haben sie gesagt so ist es aber nicht so
dass diese Weiterentwicklung auch aus
dem Grunde durch die nahto den westliche
Länder geschieht weil sie merken dass
eine gegen Eskalation wie Sie vielleicht
hätte vermutet werden können von der
russischen Förderation nicht kommt wenn
das der Fall ist sage ich mir aber er
warum wird es nicht genutzt wenn diese
gegen exkalation nicht kommt endlich mit
Friedensverhandlungen zu beginnen und
sie starten da wir unterhalten uns über
Systeme was alles aufs Gefäß fällt
gebracht werden muss und sollte aber
darüber dass irgendwann auch mal schon
oder vielleicht schon lange der Punkt da
ist diesem sterben auf dem Gesichtsfeld
ein Ende zu setzen darüber unterhalten
zufriedensverhandlungen bereit ist und
nicht unausgebildete junge Russen in
großer Zahl in dunklen Tod zu schicken
was in den letzten Monaten ja passiert
ist
wenn sie sagen also wieso müssen wir
jetzt erkennen setzt sich irgendwie
nicht mehr zu Wehr er hat nicht mehr
genügend Waffen nicht mehr genügend
Leute einfach keine militärischen Erfolg
mehr dann könnte doch sagen ich will
Waffenstillstand diese Frage diese
richtige Frage aber auch für sich selbst
beantworten und den Schritt gehen und
diesen Versuch unternehmen ich meine
jederzeit wieder zu Eskalation zu
eskalieren ist ja möglich aber diesen
Versuch allein zu Unternehmen erkennen
sie ich erkenne ihn nicht aber sie sind
schon der Meinung dass die Ukraine ein
Recht auf Verteidigung hat auf dem Tisch
überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel was
braucht sie denn dann an Waffen um sich
um diese Verteidigungsfähigkeit auch
wahrzunehmen also die Waffen diese
bekommen zeigen ja nun schon seit
Monaten das ist nicht weiter geht wieder
in die eine oder die andere Richtung
seit fünf Monaten tritt das auf der
Stelle außer dass Menschen sterben so
das wäre doch der Punkt zu sagen egal
mal wie unkonventionell eine
diplomatische Lösung auch ist sie muss
zumindest begonnen werden und es gibt ja
Möglichkeiten wir denken immer an an
den ehrlichen Makler der der Papst sein
kann oder ein brasilianischer Präsident
wir können noch mal viel näher denken
warum nicht ein Bundespräsident
Steinmeier zum Beispiel der war
Außenminister als mal da war der war der
hat Minsk verhandelt er sechs Jahre
Bundespräsident und er gehört dem es
steht dem Land vor dass die zweitgrößte
Waffenlieferung und finanzielle
Unterstützung für die Ukraine gibt er
könnte auch mal sagen als Vermittler
auftreten und sagen wir hören auf damit
wenn dann Bedingungen setzt aber kein
Versuch wird unternommen ist
unkonventionell was ich gerade gedacht
habe aber ich finde es lohnt um Menschen
Leben zurecht zu retten
wir haben jetzt gerade mehrfach gehört
F16 das ist eine Menge logistische
Aufwand Ausbildung oder müssen
ukrainische Piloten mit einem Fremden
systemvertraut gemacht werden müssen
perfekt Englisch sprechen alles läuft
über die englische Sprache das ist man
reagiert von vier bis sechs Monaten dazu
eben die logistische Unterstützung eine
Flugstunde 200 Stunden Wartung und
ähnliches wenn man sich das jetzt
anguckt und dann auch noch die
Überlegung mit einbezieht wer traut sich
als erstes F16 Flugzeuge an die Ukraine
zu liefern dann ist das ja auf der
Zeitschiene noch eine ganz schöne Zeit
bis das tatsächlich stattfindet kann
diese kann diese Waffe im aktuellen
Krieg noch eingesetzt werden im
verbundenen
oder ist das eigentlich eher eine
militärische Aufrüstung für die Zeit
nach dem Krieg damit äh die Ukraine mit
Russland nicht nur das zweite Mal das
Gleiche erleben
für Ihre Frage ist deswegen schwer zu
beantworten weil niemand weiß was
bedeutet im aktuellen Krieg wie lange
zieht er sich hin wie lange wird der
laufen insofern sie haben natürlich
recht es ist jetzt nicht was in den
nächsten Wochen Monaten was in diesem
Sommer in irgendeiner Form
in die Ukraine kommt in der
Gefechtssituation in der
Auseinandersetzung einen Unterschied
macht es ist ein politisches Signal es
ist aber und das muss man ja auch
berücksichtigen eine ein commitment oder
lieber deutsch gesagt eine Zusage eine
verbindliche Zusage dass der Westen die
Ukraine über den Krieg hinaus
unterstützt weil die Ukraine wird
völlig unabhängig davon wie lange diese
diese Auseinandersetzung dauert ihre
ganze militärische Ausstattung umstellen
und umstellen müssen
allein schon weil für
kalte sowjetisches Gerät was sie hat die
Ersatzteile zum großen Teil auch die
Munition eigentlich nur noch in Russland
produziert werden im Westen nicht mehr
verfügbar sind also irgendwann steht man
da und sagt für eine Mic für eine sue
Flugzeug kriegt man kein Ersatzteil mehr
im Westen Punkt aus auch nicht auf dem
Weltmarkt
aber eigentlich gibt es keinen anderen
Weg in die Ukraine für die Ukraine als
zu sagen langfristig stellen wir uns
technisch auf westliches militärisches
Gerät ein
aber die Strategie hat die dahinter
steckt ist ja ich habe es gerade schon
mal kurz erwähnt es ist das sogenannte
verbundene Gefecht das ist eine NATO
Doktrin wo verschiedene Waffengattungen
zusammenarbeiten
Luftwaffe Artillerie Panzertruppen
Logistik
Aufklärung in bis hin zu einem zum
Einsatz von Drohnen selber Waffen selber
Abwehr
dazu soll diese F16 ja auch dienen oder
jedenfalls
Kampfflugzeuge die Ukraine jetzt auch
bekommen hat
und die soll sie in die Lage versetzen
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert das Gebiet
den Russen militärisch wieder zu
entreißen da kommt häufiger auch der
Name Krim ins Spiel mit dieser Annektion
2014 kann er das ganze Unheil ist das
militärisch
realistisch dass es zu großen Gelände
gewinnen der Ukraine mit diesen
verbundenen Waffensystemen die wir jetzt
nach und nach liefern kommt wir bewegen
jetzt ukrainische Soldaten aus und die
lernen sehr sehr schnell und lernen
schnell dieses Thema zu bedienen aber
das ist natürlich eine Grundausbildung
und ich meine wir wissen dass die die
als Soldaten tätig gewesen sind wissen
dass eben gerade das Gefechte
verbundenen Waffen z.B eben eine längere
Übungsphase brauchen und dass man das
nicht einfach in drei Wochen lernt
sondern wir sehen ja auch beim Einsatz
der Artillerie das quasi die Ukraine
auch die
Artilleriegeschütze eben nicht nach NATO
Standards einsetzt sondern eben den
höheren taktischen Ansatz diese höhere
taktische Ausbildung noch nicht umsetzen
kann also darum bin ich mir auch nicht
so sicher ob quasi nach NATO Standards
ein gefächer verbundenen Waffen damit
F16 geführt werden kann und könnte weil
einfach der Ausbildung stand an diesen
anderen völlig anderen Waffensystemen
auch von der Philosophie noch nicht da
ist
recht und zum anderen wir haben in der
NATO immer
dafür Sorge tragen wollen dass möglichst
Waffensysteme unter dem Partner eines
Modells benutzt werden die Ukraine wird
jetzt mit allem voll gestopft also
dieser Grundsatz ist dort der vollkommen
abwegig und insofern ist das die
Operation der verbundenen Kräfte nicht
möglich aus der Ausbildungssituation aus
die er halt richtig dargestellt hat aber
genauso wie aus der materiellen und der
waffensystemsituation
noch mal von den roten Linien die
Wladimir Putin ja immer wieder zieht
damit verbunden ist oft eine
diffuse Drohung mit Atomwaffen hat er
gesagt wenn Russland tatsächlich
angegriffen wird wird es nicht mit allen
zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln
verteidigen und wird ja gar nicht
Russland von der NATO angegriffen das
ist ja ukrainisches geht gibt es aber
tatsächlich und diese Eskalation dass er
möglicherweise mit etwas droht was er
nicht wahr macht es gilt ja die nuklear
Doktrin wer im nukleakrieg als erste
schießt stirbt als zweiter aber in dem
Moment wo ist der Ukraine gelingen würde
die Grimm ja ein Symbol besondere Art
für Russland
militärisch zu erobern wäre das
vielleicht tatsächlich diese rote Linie
wo es dann neben dem
drohen mit Atomwaffen also bellende
Hunde beißen ja nicht sagt man aber dass
sie dann vielleicht doch beißen dass das
da weniger der der eine
undenkbare Invasion nach Russland
russische Kernland aber in den Grimm die
möglicherweise
Putin die Nerven verlieren lässt ja
natürlich also die die Krim ist
definitiv ein
sensitives ein sensitiver Punkt für
Russland und letztendlich wissen wir
auch nicht wo die aktuellen roten Linien
liegen denn russland hat die roten
Linien immer wieder neu gezogen von
daher kann ich Ihnen jetzt natürlich
keine 100%ige
Garantie geben dass dem nicht so ist ich
kann nur sagen was wir über das letzte
Jahr die letzten anderthalb Jahre
gesehen haben und das war das
insbesondere zu Beginn also nach Beginn
der russischen Invasion in der Ukraine
das nukleare sebelrasseln wirklich sehr
präsent war und ich meine man hat das in
Talkshows gesehen man hat das unter
einer Listen an der Liste hin gesehen da
war einfach die zu einem Atomkrieg
extrem hoch und Russland hat mit dieser
Angst auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen
gespielt sowohl im Bereich der
taktischen Atomwaffen als auch diese
Situation um das Kernkraftwerk saporice
herum als auch diese diffuse Drogen mit
einer
schmutzigen Atombombe und was wir jetzt
in den letzten sechs Monaten gesehen
haben ist allerdings dass dieses
nukleare Säbelrasseln dieses mediale
auch abgenommen hat und darüber ist man
sich auch in der NATO im klaren und ich
würde das als als ein Anzeichen dafür
definieren dass Russland verstanden hat
dass dieses nukleare Säbelrasseln auch
seine Limits hat also zum einen gab es
natürlich einen in Anführungsstrichen
Erfolg dieses säbelrasselns das war eben
die NATO den besten aus einem aktiven
Kriegsgeschehen herauszuhalten und das
war die eigentliche rote Linie die ich
am Anfang angesprochen habe nämlich
diejenige das westliche Staaten nicht
aktiv in in diesem Krieg beteiligt sind
auf der anderen Seite hat sich aber
gezeigt dass diese nuklearen Drogen
nicht führen dass die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine ablassen und deswegen ich
kann Ihnen da keine keine Garantien
geben weil ich habe natürlich jetzt auch
keine keine Glaskugel aber ein Punkt den
ich machen würde und ich glaube das ist
auch auch ganz wichtig also ich meine es
wird immer darüber geredet auf der einen
Seite sollen wir uns jetzt mit Russland
an den Tisch setzen und einfach mal ins
Blaue hinein Dialog führen oder machen
wir jetzt einfach so weiter wie es geht
ich glaube einen Ansatz der wichtig wäre
ist dass man das aktuelle
Kriegsgeschehen auch von bestimmten
anderen Politikfeldern Trend
kompartmentalisiert also dass man
beispielsweise Maßnahmen in der
nuklearen Risiko Reduktion die ja für
Russland auch interessant sind die
beispielsweise auch für China sehr
interessant sind trotzdem vorantreibt
das sind vielleicht Maßnahmen die man
jetzt momentan noch nicht umsetzen kann
aber das sind Schritte die der besten
sich langfristig überlegen kann also
Maßnahmen im Bereich der der Hotlines
der der Gesprächskanäle die ist ja immer
noch gibt was funktioniert da was
funktioniert im Bereich Transparenz und
der macht auch die Vorschritte das muss
man auch mal betonen die NATO eskaliert
nicht die Nato hat letztes Jahr das
erste Mal sehr präsent über ihre
jährliche nuklearübung stead fast nun
geredet die Amerikaner führen gerade
eine sogenannte nuklear Failsafe Review
durch wo sie wo sie
öffentlich auch kommunizieren dass die
Sorge dafür tragen dass Ihre
nuklearwaffenarsenale gesichert sind
also das sind alles Schritte die der
besten auch durchführt um zu zeigen wie
eskalieren nicht deswegen finde ich sie
können auch nicht wissen wie viel Putty
das empfindet wenn sie sagen
findet ich habe keine Glaskugel und ich
mache hier auch keine 100%igen Aussagen
also Frau Berghofer sagt hier gerade mit
dem mit der Angst also atomare Drogen
auszustoßen um Angst zu erzeugen da
hatte Pudding ganz besonders Deutschland
im Blick in dieser Frage der
Bundeskanzler hat allerdings auch
häufiger in diese Kerbe geschlagen
gesagt also wir müssen auf jeden Fall
einen Atomkrieg verhindern war das so
klug
verhindern müssen das ist glaube ich
eine Aussage der wir alle hier in der
Rolle zustimmen ich kann Ihnen sagen
viele Menschen Bedenken und ja der
Bundeskanzler auch aufgenommen die
äußern diese Bedenken auch sehr sehr
deutlich weil sie eben eine wissen dass
das eher unwahrscheinlich ist dass er
das Putin da Atomwaffen hat eben auch
gesagt am Anfang des Krieges waren auch
viele Analysten der Meinung dass eine
große Gefahr eines Atomkrieges besteht
und ich glaube da hat er sich ein guter
Gesellschaft Befunden feststellen müssen
wir das eine große Wille da ist in
Deutschland die Ukraine zu unterstützen
im in der Forderung ihre territale
Integrität wieder herzustellen das aber
gleichzeitig doch Befürchtungen da sind
und die kann ich jeden Tag an der
leserbriefspaltener Zeitung lesen am
Gesprächen auch meine Wählerinnen und
Wählern vor Ort zu Hause und da sind
stellen wir uns glaube ich ganz ganz gut
auf indem wir die Dinge stark machen die
gezeigt haben dass die Ukraine sich
halten kann nämlich wirklich Flugabwehr
bodengebundene Luftverteidigung das sind
Dinge die jetzt durch einen Game changer
in den letzten Monaten waren dafür
geführt haben dass die Ukraine weiterhin
so AG konnte wie sie agiert hat aber die
AFD hat ja die nukleare Option auch
immer für möglich gehalten und davor
gewarnt ja haben sie dabei ja zu Recht
also sie ist ja vorhanden und wenn wenn
das Potenzial zu vorhanden ist bin ich
vollkommen aber Berghofer wir können
nicht in die Glaskugel gucken aber sie
kann genutzt werden weil es ist
realistisch dass das
was ist da realistisch ich meine ähm
klausewitz hat gesagt der Krieg ist die
Bluse Fortsetzung der Politik mit
anderen Mitteln so wenn ich da an Putin
denke putin ist der ist ein Jahr jünger
als ich also der hat auch das meiste
hinter sich aber er hat er hat er hat
eine klare Option er muss diesen Krieg
für sich gewinnen und wie weit will der
Westen in reizen damit er nicht alle
Möglichkeiten tatsächlich nutzt also ich
habe da ich will nicht sagen Angst Angst
ist zu schlechter Begleiter aber
Bedenken habe ich ja das Westen
ist da und es muss unser aller ansinn
sein diesen Krieg zu beenden Helmut
Schmidt hat gesagt lieber 100 Stunden
verhandeln als eine Stunde schießen kann
ich unterstreichen also den Pudding ja
vor dem 22 Januar 2022 machen können
die Frage die sich ja in dem
Zusammenhang auch immer wieder hebt bzw
was immer wieder ins Spiel gebracht wird
ist eine geplante Frühjahrsoffensive der
Ukraine die lässt aber auf sich warten
das wissen wir nicht also wir wissen gar
nicht ob die nicht längst schon läuft
was heißt Offensive also wir müssen uns
glaube ich in diesem Krieg von manchen
traditionellen oder herkömmlichen
Vorstellungen lösen also wenn wenn das
Wort Offensive fällt dann denken viele
Menschen an die Panzer breit keine die
in großer Front Vorstoß so etwas sehen
will bislang nicht werden wir
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht sehen es
hat in den vergangenen Tagen wie es hieß
Partisanen Vorstöße auf Belgorod in in
den Russland gegeben ist das die
Eröffnung eine Offensive um Truppen von
anderen Freund Abständen abzuziehen
wissen wir nicht
also es gibt möglicherweise eine
offensiv es gibt möglicherweise eine
offensive die wir nicht sehen trotzdem
unterstützter Beobachtung dieses
Krieges wo man sieht wenn eine Maus eine
Maus vom einen Maus auch ins andere
wechselt ja die Maul muss schon halben
Meter groß sein damit man sie sieht aber
oder 30 cm groß sein
da kann ich ein vigold unterstützen es
muss eben nicht traditionell sein und
manche Offensive im cyberraum die sehen
Sie dann auch durch
Satellitenüberwachung nicht unbedingt ne
und diese Täuschungsmanöver also ich
meine die Offensive letztes Jahr
eigentlich hat sich ja dadurch
ausgezeichnet dass man erstmal ein
riesiges Täuschungsmanöver hatte und der
der Berater das Leiter des Präsidialamt
podolia hat glaube ich vor ein paar
Tagen in den Medien gesagt die Offensive
habe eben an angefangen das kann schon
einen so eine Art Täuschungsmanöver sein
wir wissen es eben nicht ich meine ich
stimme da vollkommen zu und das ist eben
diese Kreativität auch der ukrainischen
Seite
Informationen zu liefern die sich
vielleicht dann auch anders
herausstellen werden
in der Ukraine nicht mehr so viel Zeit
hier in der Sendung dass wir jetzt
gerade sehen in der Ukraine ist das
sozusagen die
strategische massive Vorbereitung dass
die Ukraine ausgestattet mit westlichen
Waffen nach einem nach Beendigung eines
wie eine wie auch immer gearteten Ende
dieses Krieges dann in die NATO
aufgenommen werden kann
naja Waffensysteme sind es ja nicht
alleine also da gehört schon einiges
mehr dazu
aber die geostrategische Reaktion ist ja
da man will es ja wahrscheinlich machen
um noch mal einen weiteren Angriff
Russlands zu verhindern das wäre
wahrscheinlich es gibt ja auch die
grundsätzliche Zusage der NATO die
Ukraine aufzunehmen und wenn die Ukraine
am es ist ja keine Voraussetzung andere
osteuropäische Länder Polen Bulgarien
Rumänien sind in die NATO eingetreten
mit ihrem ganzen alten sowjetischen
Gerät also das ist kein Direktor
zusammen und Frieden schaffen vor dem
Gift gibt für den willius sollte man
solche Themen wie jetzt eine offensiv
eine NATO-Mitgliedschaft für die Ukraine
zu diskutieren das sollte man vermeiden
die Frage stellt sich das einfach nicht
und
aber um die kommt man ja nicht rum nach
dem Krieg ich glaube vor dem Krieg war
ja klar hat man die NATO kritisiert weil
die USA dass sie diese NATO
Mitgliedschaft quasi angeboten hat jetzt
hat sich das ja quasi um 180 Grad
gedreht jetzt geht es ja gar nicht mehr
ohne naja auf jeden Fall haben die
Ukraine zum
EU-Beitrittskandidaten gemacht das ist
ja auch schon wichtiges Signal und wie
wir mit einer autoverfahren das muss man
dann entscheiden wie dann die politische
Bewertung in der entsprechenden Lage ist
ob das dann sie sehen ja das sowieso bei
Ländern wie Schweden im Moment Probleme
haben die an Bord zu bekommen weil einen
Schweden das liegt nicht an den Schweden
aber die Wahl ab am Wochenende in der
Türkei genau und dann wenn wir also
sehen ob dann nachher am Endeffekt auch
alle Mitglieder derselben Meinung sind
was eben Beitritt NATO Beitritt der
Ukraine angeht aber sind eben fragen die
stellen sich glaube ich erst wenn wir
wirklich wieder ein Frieden haben oder
einen Waffenstillstand und das ist
natürlich hoffentlich möglichst bald
was was passiert nach einem möglichen
Ende Ukraine in der EU vielleicht in der
NATO dann gibt es auch noch auf der
Landkarte weiter nach rechts guckt
Georgien ähm ja ein ähnliches Problem
ist nicht direkt involviert aber
gefährdet bekommen wir diese ganze
dieses ganze
geostatistische was will ich jetzt sagen
durcheinander da irgendwie den Griff
naja also ich glaube nur um das jetzt
mal so ich glaube das ist eine sehr
große Frage die ich wahrscheinlich in
der kürzester Zeit jetzt auch nicht
vollkommen interessieren kann aber ich
glaube
neben Georgien ja auch Moldau dass
momentan wirklich auch von Hybriden
russischen Aktivitäten sehr betroffen
ist ich glaube nur dann wenn sich die
die NATO-Länder und die europäischen
Länder
keiner Naivität hingehen was was
langfristige russische Strategien auch
im hybridenbereich angehen von denen ja
auch Deutschland betroffen ist und die
wir einfach noch nicht genug
Aufmerksamkeit haben ich glaube das wäre
so so mein Kernpunkt dass wir nicht
wieder in diese Naivität zurückfallen ob
die Ukraine jetzt Teil der NATO ist ob
sie andere Sicherheitsgarantien bekommt
aber dass man einfach langfristig und
das findet ja auch in der Natur schon
statt das Denken weiterentwickelt wie
man mit einem sehr schwierigen Russland
auf sehr sehr lange Sicht umgeht
gut dann wird wir das Beobachten sehr
sehr lange Sicht heißt auch noch viele
Phönix Runden zu diesem Thema ich
bedanke mich bei Julia Berghofer bei
Johannes Arth bei Rüdiger Lukassen bei
Thomas Wiegold Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer am Sonntag
Pfingstsonntag 12 Uhr bei Phoenix das
Karlsruhe verfassungsgespräch mit Jörg
Schönborn Thema gute Schulden schlechte
Schulden wie sinnvoll ist die schwarze
Null es geht um die
verschuldungskriterien der öffentlichen
Haushalte in unserer Verfassung aktuell
ist bei Phoenix der Tag mit Maja Weber
unter anderem das Online-Treffen der
internationalen Kontaktgruppe zu
Koordinierung von Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine dort wird das auch besprochen
was wir hier in 45 Minuten diskutiert
haben unter dem Vorsitz des
us-verteidigungsministers Leute
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]